ob der philipp heute stehe wohl bei
tische sitzen will das kennt jeder
dafür liebt jeder philipp und jeder
nicht philipp haben sie dich eigentlich
immer ist apple philipp genannt ja mein
gott mein opa andauernd gesagt das ist
ja das erstaunliche finde ich am
struwwelpeter dass diese typen die da
gezeichnet werden alle in unserem
sprachgebrauch eingeflossen sind wann es
das erschienen 844 ich weiß nicht wie
das damals war aber heutzutage ist es
schon wieder so witzig dass zu lesen
obwohl es brachial ist ja also das
schlimmste sind auf dieser abgeschnitten
ihr habt mich so etwas wie da geht die
türe auf und vereinen schnell im lauf
springt da schneider in die stube zu dem
daumenlutscher buch wer jetzt geht es
klipp und klar ab mit der er die daumen
ab mit der großen scharfen schere
legendär
dieses buch was er irgendwie also
wirklich schwarze pädagogik ist in
reinkultur ist es das was die
abschreckende mit den übelsten mitteln
hantieren pädagogik die harte tour so
wie ich es gelernt habe und so wie ich
es auch an meinen kindern praktiziere
man bringe also ich hab das buch her
meinen kindern nicht vorgelesen um sie
zu erziehen sondern um ihnen welten zu
eröffnen die anders sind als ihre
eigenen hoffe ich doch mal meine
lieblingsgeschichte ist die geschichte
vom fliegenden robert der junge der wenn
es stark regnet trotz warnung der eltern
aus dem haus geht mit einem regen und
dann fliegt er davon an die wolken stößt
er schon und der hut fliegt auch davon
schirm und robert fliegen dort durch die
wolken immer fort ich habe immer gedacht
hat er es gut der fliegt davon ist doch
herrlich also eigentlich ist ja der
fliegende robert die geradezu eine
emanzipationsgeschichte ja der robert
der sich interessiert für das was
draußen vor sich geht auch wenn die
leute ihn warnen und dann halt davon
fielen also ich finde es gibt zwei
instanzen in diesem buch einmal gibt es
einen stern mit der schere und dann gibt
es aber noch so was wie eine höhere
instanz zum beispiel die instanz die den
robert wegträgt die eltern sind die die
entweder gar nichts sagen oder die halt
warnen das lustig weil mich interessiert
diese älter
ebene aus unerfindlichen gründen was ist
denn deine lieblingsgeschichte philipp
meine lieblingsgeschichte ist die
geschichte vom will jäger wobei der
jäger überhaupt nicht wild es in dieser
geschichte sondern der hase ist welt es
geht darum dass der jäger einschläft
weil die sonne scheint und dann kommt
der hase und schnappt sich eben nicht
nur das gewehr sondern auch brille und
fängt dann an auf den jäger anzulegen
wobei ich auch relativ wichtig finde
dass er ihnen ja nicht irgendwie
erschießt oder so es endet mit und des
häuschens kind der kleine haas der
hockten grünen gras dem floss der kaffee
auf die nase er schrie er hat mich da
verbrannt und hielt den löffel in der
hand dieser löffel der überhaupt nicht
eingeführt ist und einfach nur völlig
irre ist damit der raum mit einem reim
abschließt es ist ein großartiges
anarchisches ende